So I just want to talk about this image that
Cajal drew, of the retina of the lizard.
Cajal was very excited about the retina, I
think in part because of his connection to
it as an artist.
And what's really interesting about this image
is that he's depicted many different types
of retinal ganglion cells.
And in particular there are many different
types and we know now that the reason for
these different types is to do with the function
of these different cells.
At the time, Cajal would not have known what
the functions were because he was not able
to image live tissue.
But he was able to notice that these things
did have different types, and therefore could
postulate that maybe the functions would be
different.
And I think this is a testament to what Cajal
was able to infer with the limited data that
he had, as well as how we are then able to
use that information with new techniques,
and being able to do imaging within live animals
to determine the really interesting and varied
functions of these different types of cells.
So here, you have cells that might correspond
to, for example, seeing a red or green object
in the world, or seeing a moving object or
a still object.
And now we know a lot more about the retina
because of these new functional techniques.